[Music]
so
i wanted to acknowledge the devastating
loss of a dear friend and member of the
marvel studios family
chadwick boseman was an immensely
talented actor and an inspirational
individual
who affected all of our lives
professionally and personally
his portrayal of t'challa the black
panther is iconic
and transcends any iteration of the
character in any other medium from
marvel's past
and it's for that reason that we will
not recast the character
however to honor the legacy the chad
helped us build through his portrayal of
the king of wakanda
we want to continue to explore the world
of wakanda
and all of the rich and varied
characters introduced in the first film
writer director ryan coogler is hard at
work on the sequel now and will bring
the film to you in theaters
july 8th 2022
we've got a lot in store at marvel
studios and disney plus is key
to the interconnection and expansion of
the mcu it will be home for both our
feature films and our series
for years and years to come since marvel
first joined disney back in 2009
bob iger's been the biggest champion of
the work that we do none of this
would have been possible without his
support so it is now my pleasure to turn
things back over to bob
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new marvel black panther 2 movie
video obviously kevin feige has been
talking a lot about what's going on with
the new version of black panther 2 that
ryan coogler is working on right now so
i'll explain what he said and what it
means about the future of that franchise
what he's talked about the characters
what it's going to explore how the story
has changed and how that's tied up in
the future of the mcu with the other
movies like fantastic four
in avengers 5. so if you're new to the
channel we're doing a giveaway for
disney plus memberships because of wand
division starting all you have to do to
enter is just be a subscriber and let me
know what you want them to do with the
future black panther movies because of
course there will be more sequels
probably the biggest thing that he talks
about there the biggest revelation is
that they will not recast
chadwick boseman as t'challa so there
obviously will be more black
panthers he doesn't say that they won't
have more black panthers he's saying
that they won't have more t'chalas they
won't bring in another actor and in a
separate video recently when he was
doing one division interviews he also
addressed that they wouldn't have a cg
version of chadwick boseman they're not
going to do any kind of star wars rise
of skywalker
carrie fisher situation where they try
to rework a digital version of them
into scenes with other actors chadwick
bosun will continue to be an important
part of the story of black panther 2
very critical to what's actually
happening with the plot but just not in
the way that you expected before
then kevin feige's other big revelation
is that the story will focus
more on the world of wakanda itself so
in the way the first black panther movie
in avengers infinity war sort of gave us
the cliffs notes
version of wakanda we learned a little
bit about it there's so many different
groups different religions
different fighting forces all vying for
control within wakanda
we just saw like a brief taste of that
when t'challa was taking the throne
during the first black panther movie
like are there any challengers then
umbaku steps up
if you haven't read any of the black
panther comics or you've only read some
of them or it's been a long time
there was actually more recent run i
think it was volume 6 of black panther
the tahana kasi coats did that was a
more complex
look at the structure in the inner
workings of wakandan society so it's
actually probably a good place to go to
just to get the deep dive into wakanda
you may have also seen the recent rumors
that dr doom might be the main villain
for black panther 2 because there is a
long
rich history between dr doom in the
world of wakanda and black panther
character in the comics
as well as a really deep connection to
the fantastic four with the black
panther character
in fact if you're not a big comic book
reader in general the black panther
character
debuted for the first time in the comics
in fantastic four number 52
and during that big disney plus
presentation that kevin feige did for
all the different shows in the upcoming
movies
right after he dropped this teaser for
what's going on during black panther 2
he did the big revelation about their
new version of the fantastic
four movie so he's mentioning new mcu
fantastic four in black panther two in
the same breath meaning that those
movies will probably share some sort of
connection at least on a surface level
even if the new fantastic four movie
doesn't come out till a couple movies
after black panther 2
because black panther 2 is firmly summer
2022 and we're probably not gonna see
fantastic four until 2023
maybe like a year later the big
connection between doctor doom and black
panther character is that
just like a lot of other big marvel
villains he wanted their vibranium there
was this big arc in the comics called
doom war where he basically takes his
army of doom bots and it weighs wakanda
eventually takes it over and also tries
to hijack black panther's connection to
boss the panther goddess where a lot of
their more cosmic abilities come from he
tries to steal the powers of black
panther's god
it is the most doctor doom thing that
you could possibly do that's one of the
beauties of the doctor doom character is
that he's both a man of science
and a man of magic so you could actually
put him in a movie like doctor strange
like doctor strange versus doctor doom
it would be really awesome
they also have a long history of teaming
up in the comics or you could even put
them up against one of the more
science-based avengers like iron man
obviously
iron man in the present day of the mcu
no longer around
but the fantastic four obviously very
technologically inclined group
the other big reason why that do-more
doctor doom storyline is a big deal is
because that's also the black panther
arc where shuri
became a version of the black panther
taking the mantle from t'challa briefly
the whole connection between black
panther and the fantastic four is that
way back in fantastic four number 52
they get an invitation from black
panther to come to wakanda and just
see this mystery land that nobody has
ever been to before
when they arrived they wind up fighting
black panther because obviously this is
comics so if you show up with a brand
new character of course they're gonna
fight before they become friends
they eventually chill out and t'challa
reveals that he was just testing them
and asked them here to help him deal
with ulysses claw who's come to try and
steal their vibranium so obviously we've
already done ulysses claw in the black
panther and the other marvel movies
but the whole concept of vibranium is
still a really important thing in the
background one of the most precious
resources on planet earth
just because we made it through the
whole killmonger adventure with him
trying to send vibranium weapons
all over the earth to armed militias to
just sort of take over the planet
and we made it through avengers endgame
doesn't mean that everybody in the mcu
is going to stop
wanting vibranium also with the death of
black panther you also have a question
of who's going to take the throne
most people would think that shuri is
going to become the next black panther
because technically she's his successor
she's the next in line for the throne
but anybody in wakanda can challenge for
the throne so umbaku could challenge for
the throne if he wants and there's no
way that shuri is going to defeat him
without her technology
and if you've seen their fights they
depower themselves
you can't use any special vibranium
weapons it basically has to be a knock
down drag out fight
old school style there's no way that
shuri could beat mbaku in a fight like
that
there was some news about casting one of
the other minor villains he could wind
up being white tiger or one of the other
big black panther villains
there are a number of different
religious cults that all worship
different gods inside wakanda
the panther cult is just the main one
that black panther worships that's their
connection to boss the panther god
doctor strange is probably one of the
most important characters during marvel
phase 4 because of all this multiverse
and doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness is kind of the
culmination of all that you have
characters like dr
voodoo but there's also people within
wakanda that practice
different kinds of magic that are a
little bit different from the magic that
doctor strange practices like they're
more like shamans but it's the same idea
different kinds of magic inside the mcu
and if doctor doom is going to wind up
being one of the villains that would be
amazing if he was
they could also start to set up the idea
of the cabal
in the background even though they're
more like the evil version of the
illuminati and we haven't got to the
illuminati in the mcu yet
but now that we have the x-men and the
fantastic four characters they can
actually do that eventually strangely
enough nobody asked kevin feige any
questions about illuminati but they did
ask him about avengers 5 and he's like
oh yeah that's a pretty cool name
avengers maybe we'll use it again for
some movies
like hell yeah we're gonna do more
avengers movies avengers movies for
disney are kind of like licenses to
print money so there's no way they're
ever gonna stop making avengers movies
the whole idea though with the black
panther franchise is that before
chadwick boseman passed away he was
going to become one of the linchpins
of the mcu going forward into marvel
phase 4 phase 5 through all the x-men
the fantastic four stuff
all the bigger avengers secret war stuff
down the line he was probably one of
their most important characters next to
spider-man
they'll be filming the black panther 2
movie before too long so we'll hear
more news about castings and who the
villains are going to be and how they're
going to invoke all these x-men
characters
because around the time the black
panther drops around the time of the
fantastic four movie that's when we're
going to see the transition
from marvel phase 4 to marvel phase 5
and marvel phase 5 is
really where you'll see the rebooted
version of the x-men start running
around a lot
but i am expecting them to introduce a
lot of fantastic four stuff
easter eggs and x-men easter eggs
mutants before that
especially starting in the one division
series my full one division episode
videos are going to start posting on
friday it'll be a weekly show so make
sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss any of those everyone let me
know in the comments though what do you
just want them to do with the black
panther character and their franchise
going forward if we have all this big
fantastic four and x-men stuff spinning
up
into secret wars eventually while you
wait for everything everyone click here
for that brand new wandavision episode
one
scene and click here for that brand new
marvel fantastic four
teaser video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and i'll see
you in the next video